hello everyone and welcome to the feeder
Grand Prix 2019 these are the
quarterfinals it's worthless all versus
Eric Eric in a lot we have already
suggested this game even though it just
ended which can only mean one thing
it's a very nice game and we even do
have a nice photo also compliments of
Nicky Riga the official photographer of
the feeder Grand Prix dairy habit
Sergey already knows what he's gonna
play as Wesley is on the move so let's
just enjoy that for a second and as it
is you know first day to play to
classical games then to wrap it into
shorter wraps as it goes
they've drew their to classical games
then during the rapid games
Wesley won one game and Kirk in won one
game so they had to go into more rapid
then both of the rapid games were again
drawn or the first two were drawn and
then the the other two rapid both of
them won't each game don't really not
really sure I'll have to check but then
we go into the Blitz game so here this
is the first game of the Blitz section
and Wesley has the white pieces let's
enjoy the game so Wesley opens with c4
we have being rich opening night to have
sex with Knight to c3 and c5 Knight to
f3 we have Knight to c6 the four Knights
defense the four Knights line of the
English we have g3 preparing to
fianchetto the light square Bishop and
now Bishop to b4 car can already had
this position with the black pieces he
played it against maxime beaugeois graph
in the cote d'ivoire
boots tournament in Abidjan that game
ended in a draw but here it's a bit
different with Bishop to g2 and now
castles sorry it was the same up until
this point here is where the game
deviates because here maxim went castles
and Wesley that goes for a different
line Knight to d5 castling is the main
line id5 is the second favorite here so
you can choose what to do here you don't
really want to capture you should move
the bishop if you capture then you don't
really get to punish white for playing
with the same piece twice in the opening
because of nice to d4 and now okay you
don't capture the pawn here because root
key just wins for black pretty much you
would have to move the knight and then
lose the e2 pawn and other than that you
can just capture on f7 and
and you have some compensation for the
two points but what you can do after
Knight to d4 is just capture and after
he captures just continue you can castle
and both players have a double D pawn
but the white position is a little bit
better so black isn't interested in that
so after 95 with Bishop to c5 of course
you don't want to trade and you don't
want your Bishop to be captured with
castles by Wesley and now d6 with III
and here we enter into a very famous
game here Magnus Carlsen for example had
this position against young Christophe
Duda in the world blitz championship in
sankt-petersburg in 2018 will do that
continued Bishop to b6 and Magnus
Carlsen won that game but here we have
worked eh by kurakin and we enter the
game Tony miles versus vasily smyslov in
Tilburg 1984 a very nice game that Tony
miles won against miss love but the game
very quickly you know leaves that game
we have d4 here the same as Tony maws
played against miss love
but now Smith went Bishop to b6 whereas
kurakin goes for the strongest line
Bishop to g4 so kirkin improves on the
game miles played against Smith's love
in 1984 and he plays the strongest move
Bishop to g4 so what's the idea okay if
the bishop is captured then efore is
played but there is no better move here
for y so Wesley was for it with D
captures on c5 and now he for just
attacking the pin piece h3 will not help
you because after the pawn captures your
Bishop is also under attack so you have
to give the piece back one way or
another
Wesley just please Knight back to c3 now
with ideas of capturing an e4 just
grabbing the pawn and as you have to
give up the piece one way you know you
should do it in the most favorable way
for it for you with Knight to e5 Karekin
brings yet another attacker to the f3
square so now you have to decide what to
do here you could just play the simple
Knight captures on e4 give up the piece
this way and after Knight captures
continue playing the game black will be
better of course a much more active and
you don't want to do this as it's
already blitz and you are worse as white
so Wesley did the only thing he could he
played a night capture
on e5 he said okay I'm gonna give up the
Queen but what am I getting in return
well Kara can accept the challenge of
course Bishop capture some d1 with
Knight captures on f7 now attacking the
Queen here and while you can capture a
carbine doesn't capture right away
because after looking after sandy one
sure there is nothing right away you can
do against the the White King but you
can imagine something like b3 being
played Bishop coming here assuming this
diagonal and maybe if sorry this
diagonal sorry this diagonal and if the
light square bishop somehow finds his
way over over let's say this diagonal
the black King could be somewhat exposed
so before that Queen to e7
now kurakin prepares to capture the
knight it this way and Wesley just grabs
another pawn while he's at it
Knight captures on d6 with pawn captures
C captures and now Queen captures on b6
and rook captures on d1 so what does
Wesley have as compensation for his
sacrifice Queen well it's not nothing he
does have the bishop prepare and well
for the moment the bishop pair isn't
doing all that much this bishop is just
attacking this pawn really you don't
really have in any chance of capturing
and this bishop also not doing all that
much but if you get the bishop to you
know fully operational if they are on
optimal squares then the two of them are
basically dealing twice as damaged as as
the Queen so you know it all depends
so Queen to e5 Sergei gets the Queen out
of the way and now Bishop to d2 Wester
just continues like he didn't just
sacrifice the Queen she wants to play
pawn to b3 solidify the structure on the
Queen side and somehow get his pieces
into the game with rook a to d8 by
Kerrigan and now Bishop the e1 Wesley
doesn't mind trading some rocks but
kirkin just improves his position b 60s
preparing a5 with b3 by Wesley and now
rook to d3 saying that okay I'm now
ready to double up on the D file here
and you can maybe its capture here but
then I'm getting a past deep on and here
Wesley does it with rook captures pawn
captures and now Wesley feed his light
square bishop so that's you know one
plus but on the other hand the problem
is that this past pawn is already on
these
three so rook to d1 preparing to you
know fight to the past pawn rook to d8
Sergei puts the room behind a passed
pawn and now Bishop to f1 just attacking
the passport and here is where Sergei
definitely could have continued better
he played the Queen to f5 just defended
the pawn what he could have done is d2
is just a very nice move which white
can't really capture with the bishop
because then rook captures rook captures
Queen captures here and black is just
winning what black what white would have
to do is capture with the rook and then
go into this rook captures Bishop
captures and then Knight to e4 with a
double attack here after Knight captures
Queen captures you would have this
position where the Queen fights the
bishop pair but the bishop pair isn't
still fully operational so we would
probably have plenty of time to go you
know grabbing some Queen side pawns and
then start pushing your own Queen side
pawns
so after Bishop to f1 this is what Saiga
could have done and he also could have
gone nice to e4 also a very nice move
after captures captures rook to d2
preventing pawn pushing up the pawn but
then the bishop pair really isn't doing
all that much you want to push g5 push
g4 and completely a lock of the bishops
out of the game so after this the Queen
to f5 move not the greatest continuation
by seven but okay it's a blitz game you
know Knight to d5 a very nice maneuver
by Wesley figuring out how to get the
bishops operational Knight captures on
d5 and now first rook captures on d3 now
you can't move the knight because you're
gonna look the lose the rook here and
the problem is first King to f8 is what
Cara can play the problem is if you
don't play King to a fate if you start
with something like a five you can
easily see something like this happen
especially when you're quickly
calculating lines during the Blitz game
for example captures captures captures
you think okay I'm winning but Bishop c4
you lose the Queen you're no longer
winning you're just lost
so of course in a blitz game you don't
want to keep your king on a light square
if your opponent has a light square
Bishop but if your opponent has the
bishop pair then there's really no such
thing as a safe square for King but
still King to a fate you don't want it
on a white square for the moment
C captures on d5 now Wesley
gets a passed pawn and it's a nicely
protected passport because it's
protected would attacked it because now
if you capture it you still can't
capture because of Bishop to b4 check
now if you go to light squares again we
get this line where the roof is free
because of Bishop to c4 and if you play
King to e8 then you get E for and I'm
not a very nice idea Queen captures rook
e3 again picks up the Queen so before
that correcting plays a5 preventing the
ship to be forecheck
but now rook to d4 again Wesley it
defends the point indirectly because now
if pawn captures rook f4 again picks up
the Queen so Queen the b1 by kurakin
attacking the bishop here and also da to
pawn but now we have Bishop to c3 and
now already you see what's happening the
thing we discussed the bishop is now on
c3 on this diagonal if this bishop comes
to c4 and grabs hold of this diagonal
the rook can start harassing the black
King woodwork to f4 the bishop pair is
almost fully operational
so kurakin grabs opponenet to with Queen
captures and now Bishop to c4 we have
Queen to c2 attacking the bishop here
but now rope to f4 check King to e7 and
Bishop captures and g7 and here Kirkenes
the last basically a good move here it
was rook captures on d5 but it's hard to
see such move in a blitz game not really
sure how much time he had because here
you cannot capture the rook and
basically we just eliminated a very
strong passed pawn if you capture it
then just queen d1 checking g2 Queen
captures with check and once you block
it you're also gonna eliminate the b3
point and now you have to connect it
pass force on the Queen side which will
nicely compensate for all the trouble
you're gonna get on the Kings side but
here Cara can played rook to b6
and now of course you will see wisely
played if you don't see it right away
for free to even pause the video
I mean it's a very nice idea as the two
bishops are are fully operational now so
for those of you who saw it
congratulations I mean it's not all that
difficult to move and for the we just
want to enjoy the show Bishop to f8
check and the point is not to capture
the rook but rather to capture the
Queen because the King doesn't have all
that many squares the rook controls dese
correspond controls e6 Bishop pushes the
King back
so King the d7 was played and now of
course you're not gonna capture the rook
first Bishop to b5 check and now what do
you play if the King goes up the board
then you just grab a free rook so kirkin
had to play King to c7 and here of
course it comes
ruk to c4 check picks up the Queen and
it was in this position that Sergei
kerkini resigned the game and well what
if you resign you will have to capture
if you don't want to give up your Queen
for free but first black will capture
the rook with check so lets up captures
with checking captures and now pawn
captures and black has no counter play
here it's completely winning for white
no point in continuing
and since Westley was able to draw his
blues game with the black pieces it
means that mostly saw has eliminated
Sergey Kerrigan from the quarterfinals
of the FINA Grand Prix 2019 really an
insane game really you know Wesley going
all pirate mode against Carrick and I
really enjoyed it and this is a you know
the kind of chess game that everyone
enjoys so I really do hope you enjoyed
it so that's it for this grand prix for
for sir game but you know there are
other Grand Prix's and other tournaments
and in he will obviously be there but
Wesley continues and he's waiting for
his opponents in the semi finals so
we're gonna show at least one more game
from the quarterfinals and then we're
gonna discuss the standings and who
kicked you out and you know some more
but for the moment this is it yeah
I would like to thank Michael buck for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the feed a
Grand Prix continuing the couple on the
saga and of course checking up in your
suggestions such as this one thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day